hey gq i'm queen naja and i'm going
undercover on the internet
this is actually me
[Music]
twitter
[Music]
juba tron don't know how to pronounce it
try my best
queen eyes you can sing for real where
have i been matter of fact
where are these vocals in my throat
if you guys don't know i grew up singing
in church so i got some range that i
don't show people
all the time because most of my songs
are high be
relatable and i'm not always belting
things out on my songs but i'll show you
from time to time
if you don't know like this guy here
where have you been where have you been
you know joined the queendom it's
amazing over here
okay somebody put a picture and
said why does femme drake look like
queen nash
what drake as a female and they said it
looked like me
nah nah b i'm sorry you wrong on this
one i don't see that
they tripping you know i feel like
people like this just be some haters you
know darn well don't look like that you
are hating stop
it i'm beautiful okay okay
okay next up we got youtube
[Music]
black film guild why did she sign to a
major
if she hit billboard while she was
unsigned makes no sense in 2019.
this is how i look at it you could be
independent if you want to each his own
you know
but me i have no idea what to do like as
an independent artist having a label is
also helpful you have a big giant
machine behind you of people that are
working for you
i have two kids i don't got time to be
out here trying to do all the things
that the label do for me i would rather
just pay the people
to work for me and that's that you know
what works for you works for you what
works for me works for me
period next all right i tweeted
good men are hard to find so if you have
a good one hold on to him
don't expect him to be perfect but
expect him to know your worth
and some guy named dmorty4 asks
but are you a good woman though and what
defines a good man
yes i'm a great woman that explains why
i have a good man
well no that's not true not all good
women attract good men cause i've
attracted some
not so good man yes i'm a great woman i
need some work everybody needs some work
i gotta use some improvement but i'm a
good woman overall
and what defines a good man i guess
that's to each his own
for me a man that respects you a man
that tries to understand you
a man that don't have you looking stupid
a man with dreams and goals and don't
want to leech
and and lay up off you ambitious man
good man
all right queen do you mind sharing the
gym routine that was provided to you
i'm not sure what to do in the gym i'm
not sure what to do in the gym either
that's the truth like
that's why i need a trainer because when
i'm alone i kind of don't know what to
do i might
break some equipment some good cardio is
easy if you want to do some jumping
jacks jump rope
run up and down the stairs 40 times when
i go to sleep by the end of the night i
don't remember what i did so
i'm the wrong person to ask posted
[Music]
let's see angel medina asked why legend
a grown man
in a baby's body i don't know maybe he
looks like his dad
his dad looks like a baby with a beard
so they kind of just intertwine clarence
has a baby face they look like
copy and paste he has like his dad's
attitude so it's funny
okay
[Music]
bonnabee asked has anyone else noticed
the look in claire's eyes
when he's doing something for queen i
mean i haven't noticed because when he's
doing something for me he's probably in
secret so i won't find out until the
surprise so
i don't notice but i do notice the look
in his eye when he look at me sometimes
and it's a good look it's a look that
might get me in trouble
it's a look that might get me pregnant
just kidding
okay ashley valentine what type of games
cj play for example gta call of duty no
cj is not allowed to play gta gta is a
very bad
game for kids you're not supposed to
just slap people out their cars and
steal them and drive them
cj can't play that he likes to play um
mario
you know kid friendly games he likes to
be on tick-tock
dancing i barely see him play games
okay last question of youtube andrea
degeneres would you ever start back
vlogging every day like you used to
i felt like people wasn't taking me
serious because i was a youtuber before
a singer
but i kept my family brand and i stopped
doing the queen naija vlogs
just because i wanted to focus on my
music more i just wanted people to take
me more serious but now
i realize that as i'm doing more
shopping maybe i need to start that
youtube back up because um that was my
bag that nobody could touch
so i might for you guys in for my own
bag
but i'm not sure when and i'm not sure
if i'll be consistent with it
that's my answer
wikipedia
[Music]
her birth name queen naija was given to
her by her mother
yes true queen was inspired by her
grandmother who had the same first name
and naja represented her father's name
oh this is all true yes
my father's name i think it was like
something like
muhammad naji or something like that
a lot of people ask me am i nigerian
because i guess that's also like a
nickname for nigerians
maybe my mom spelled it wrong i think it
was supposed to be n-a-j-a-h
actually which means success in arabic i
did my research and yeah she just kind
of spelt it wrong but there's no need to
go back
to the office and change it because
people know me as this now so
i guess i'm stuck with the nigerian
question forever
queen naija formerly known as queen
bulls okay
saying my government name like that
first gained prominence
as a contestant on the 13th season of
american idol
she had auditioned two years earlier but
had failed to advance to the next round
that's true you guys we drove all the
way to south carolina y'all from
michigan okay
wasted gas money and everything oh my
god the very first audition it was like
a little cubicle i forgot what this
guy's name was
but like i was singing i was thinking i
was killing it i was still nervous
though
he was like you're pitchy come back next
year
y'all i was crushed i was so crushed
like i don't even know why i went back a
second time
so i went back and i made it to the top
i think 50 or 40
and then when they sent me home again i
was like yeah this is not just just not
for me i was ready to go home my dreams
was crushed again but
i was just like yeah i'm maybe this is
not the way maybe
making a song called medicine is the way
but i never knew that then
okay in january 2018 she released the
song medicine
she was an unsigned social media star at
this time and the song made number
45 debut on the billboard hot 100. i
don't know
i guess it didn't hit me back then
because i didn't even know about the
numbers on the billboard spots and all
that stuff i wasn't
into that but now looking back that's a
pretty good spot to be in as an unsigned
artist
so i did that and look what happened
your girl is here at gq magazine
doing a whole interview we did good
okay more twitter questions because
twitter is
something else i am cardi bori i guess
this is a fan page of
cardi b's which i'm a fan of cardi do
you think we have a cardi
and queen nigel collab coming a medicine
slash bodak yellow hit
i don't know about y'all but i would
definitely live for it yeah so i haven't
collab with carter yet i would love to
we've talked about it but you know
people's schedules be like this and
cardi's a very busy woman
so i'm hoping for it one day but it'll
all happen in due time
next because i simone asked is it just
me or queen naja favors aretha
franklin in her younger days i don't see
the resemblance
but if they do i guess to each his own
maybe i need to go look at a picture of
her in her younger days but hey i mean
everybody got their own opinion
you know aretha a legend so oh my
favorite legend
let's see crown me queen b
actually no i'm queen b thank you
because my last name start with a b
so i'm the real queen bee thank you
what's going on with queen naija i mean
that's a very broad question
what's going on with me i'm getting
ready for my album i'm about to drop the
best r b
album of 2020. let's fight let's talk
about it
you know what i'm saying look at my
twitter look at my instagram
maybe you'll see all right
okay back to youtube okay we're going
back
my forehead looked big okay jessica
whimser asked what is your skincare
routine beautiful thank you let's see so
i guess when i wear makeup now
i wipe it off at the end of the night
because i used to
not do it i used to want to just stay
looking pretty all night until i fell
asleep
now wipe off my makeup i use pond's
makeup remover lotion
and i just put it all over my face until
it gets the same color as my makeup
and then i wipe it off with a neutrogena
makeup wipe and i do that about two
times
and then i use this tumeric bar so
to scrub my face and it exfoliates it
and then after that i use this kind of
toner that has alcohol in it it dries
everything out i use that with a pad
make sure everything's gone
and then i moisturize it with some
oils that's my skin routine and yeah i'm
trying to drink some more water
do that all right you guys
najma xo asked will you be doing a world
tour
after your album drops please come to
london i would love to do a world tour
you know only one thing i'm scared
i'm scared to fly to different places
other than america
i feel like things happen to planes
outside of america like they just
disappear or they crash more
so other than that like if i could swim
to
london i probably would i'm gonna do it
it's just a little scary so
bear with me
[Music]
and that's it you guys that's all for
you guys i know you're gonna miss me but
i'm signing off